The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
So more of the same in terms of
cryptography and cryptographic
techniques similar
to Tuesday's lecture.
So if you liked it,
you'll like this one.
If you didn't like
it, well, it's
going to be more of
the same, so sorry.
But what we're
going to do today is
do a couple of things a
little bit differently.
We're going to talk
about encryption.
So we talked about
hashing, which, of course,
you know about from the
use of dictionaries.
We haven't really talked about
encryption in 046 or even
in 006 previously.
But we look at two different
kinds of encryption algorithms.
We spend a little bit of time
on symmetric key encryption,
which is really something that
was used in encoding machines
including the enigma from World
War II that you probably saw
if you saw The Imitation Game.
So there you have
a shared secret.
And it's that single,
what's called,
symmetric shared secret.
Both parties know the secret.
And very quickly, we'll
talk about what it means
to actually exchange a secret.
So we'll talk
about key exchange.
And then I'll move to
asymmetric key encryption, which
I alluded to a
little bit when we
talked about digital
signatures last time.
I talked about public
keys and private keys.
But we're going to
actually look at a couple
of different public key
encryption algorithms today.
The classical algorithm, the
very first algorithm really
that stayed secure,
the RSA algorithm.
It stands for Rivest,
Shamir, and Adleman,
the initials of the
three inventors,
invented at MIT in 1977
and still in use today.
And the last part
of today's lecture
is going to be
looking at hardness.
So in encryption, if you
don't know the secret key,
it should be hard
for an adversary
to discover what the
message corresponds to.
The adversary sees what's
called the cipher text, which
is the encrypted text.
The adversary does not
know the secret key.
If he or she knows the
secret key, game over.
But assuming that adversary
does not know the secret key,
it should be computational hard
to discover the message, right?
That makes sense.
So there's clearly
a relationship
between this hardness
and NP-complete problems,
which are computationally hard.
And it's not
surprising that people
have tried to build what are
called cryptosystems, which
are essentially cryptographic
techniques, based
on the hardness of
NP-complete problems,
including graph
coloring and knapsack
and so on and so forth.
But it turns out there's
a real subtle difference
between the kinds of problems
that have been useful in terms
of building secure
cryptosystems like RSA
and NP-complete problems.
And we'll talk about that
at the end of lecture.
We'll probably spend a
bunch of time on that.
So let's get started with the
symmetric key encryption, which
is, at some level,
kind of boring
from a mathematical standpoint.
So we want to spend
a lot of time on it.
It's definitely very useful.
It essentially assumes that
there's a secret key k.
And you can think of
this as a 128-bit number.
Some people want it
to be larger, 256.
But it's suddenly at 64.
At this point, it's
probably not enough,
even though 2 raised to 64 is
still a fairly large number.
With parallelism and
with fast computers,
it's a little worrisome
that the adversary only
requires 2 raised to
64 work to enumerate
all possible secret
keys of 64-bits right?
So 122 raised to
128 is much better.
And this is shared
between Alice and Bob.
So we'll think about
the protagonists
here as being Alice and Bob.
And they want to
exchange information.
And typically, the adversary
is mal for malicious.
But there's other ways you can
obviously name adversaries.
So the basic equation here
is really straightforward.
It's C, which is
the cipher text.
So a little terminology
here, cipher text.
m is the plain text
or the message.
And plain text means
you can just read it.
Cipher text means
it's scrambled.
K is, of course, the
secret key that's up here.
And the e is the
encryption function.
Now, in symmetric
key cryptography,
basically the
requirement is that you
have to be able to get back
the plain text from the cipher
text given a public decryption
function and knowledge
of the secret key.
And this should be a
straightforward operation,
right?
So by the way, e of k m, this
is a polytime computation.
It's not constant time.
It's typically linear time.
And you don't really want it
to be quadratic time even,
because you want to do
this vary fast, streaming.
You need to send
streams of messages,
many gigabytes potentially,
that are all encrypted.
And this is actually
what happens
when you get stuff
from your satellite
and you're downloading movies.
That's exactly what happens.
It's symmetric key
encryption of a lot of data.
So backwards would be dk c.
And the only difference
here is that everything else
stays the same.
This is our decryption function.
All right.
So that's symmetric
encryption is.
And there's a requirement
of reversibility here.
So it's a lot different
from one way hashes
that we talked about last time.
Because here, while you want
going from c to m to be hard,
it's only hard if the
adversary doesn't know k.
If anybody knows k,
it should be easy.
In fact, that e and
d are going to be
virtually identical
in terms of complexity
and sometimes implementation.
It's just you run it in
reverse, and you get back
what you encrypted.
That's the way you
want to think about it.
So really what happens is that
you need reversible operations
in order to build e or d,
which are the encryption
and the decryption functions.
So permutation, for
example, is reversible.
You can always take
something and permute it,
and you can go backwards.
So you could do
something like that.
And the permutation, the
reverse, looks like that.
What is this supposed to be?
It's the fact that
I have 3 bits here.
And they turn into
3 bits over there.
And obviously, if I
reverse the permutation
and if I just add a simple
thing where it was abc
and I'm going to
convert it to cba,
then cba can go
back to abc through
the reverse permutation.
So clearly, this is a
reversible operation.
But there are other operations
that are reversible as well.
Plus can be reversed
by a negation.
And exclusive OR is
simply exclusive OR.
Because if you do A exclusive
OR B, then you get C.
And imagine if you did B
again to that, you get A back.
That's what I mean by reversal.
Because you have, essentially,
A exclusive OR A cancels out.
And so it's something like a
exclusive OR B exclusive OR B
again would give you A.
So if you go look at AES, for
example, which is the Advanced
Encryption Standard, is really
only about four lines of code,
maybe it's eight lines of code.
But this is a well
used, it has been around
for a while, symmetric
key cipher that
runs in 128-bit mode as
well as 256-bit mode.
And it's, like I said,
a few lines of code.
And you'll see operations
like this, permutations.
And you'll see hat symbols
if you see a C program, which
is exclusive OR.
And you can see the
encryption and the decryption
are identical in implementation.
You're just going to run it
one way, and you run it again.
And you get back the result.
Because these permutations
are reversible.
And the hats are reversible.
And they're all signed
integers, so you're just
sort of adding them up.
And it's just
complement arithmetic,
so that looks the same as well.
So I encourage you to
go take a look at AES.
I'm not going to
spend more time on it.
The key idea here is of
symmetry and reversibility.
We're going to move
away from that.
Clearly, we didn't
talk about that
when we talked about one way
hash functions, et cetera.
That was a different situation
where we had no secrecy.
But here, we wanted symmetry.
The big question
that you would ask
and you should ask yourself
when you see this, you say,
OK great.
I can build symmetric key
encryption algorithms.
They're actually, I would
say, somewhat easier
to do than to build
hash functions, which
have a whole lot of more
interesting properties
and hard to obtain properties
like collusion resistance.
But the question really
is how do Alice and Bob
share the secret key, k?
So you need that.
You need this 128-bit
number in order
for there to be a channel,
a secure channel, that Alice
can communicate to Bob
with and vice verse.
And so now you could say
Alice sends Bob a letter.
But you know, mal could
intercept that letter.
And even worse, what wants
to do is look at the letter,
actually deliver
the letter, which
is the best thing for
him, and Alice and Bob
think that they have
a secure channel.
That's sort of best case
scenario for mal, right?
So you could have mal
in the middle here.
And you've got to worry
about stuff like that.
So key exchange, let's move
on to talk about key exchange.
And how does the secret
key k get shared?
You can't put this out
on a website, right?
So it has to be
the case, sharing
is something that has to
be secure in the sense
that there can't be
any eavesdroppers.
So here's my favorite example
of a puzzle that most of you
have probably heard about.
But those of you who haven't,
it's really pretty cool.
And those of you who have, it's
still pretty cool and worth
recalling.
And there's actually
something that you probably
haven't thought about
very much even if you've
heard about this puzzle.
That's the mathematical
assumption made
in the solution of this puzzle.
That will be interesting to you.
But the puzzle is
a pirate puzzle.
So you've got Alice and Bob.
Let's call it the
Caribbean, because that's
my favorite ocean.
And Alice and Bob are in
two different islands.
And we all know there are
pirates in the Caribbean,
right?
And so Alice and Bob want to
communicate with each other.
And what Alice has are a bunch
of boxes and locks and keys.
She's got the keys for
her locks and nothing else
and the same thing with Bob.
So Bob has boxes, locks,
keys for his locks
that he can put on his boxes.
And in this case, Alice wants
to send a message to Bob.
And Alice wants to
exchange a key with Bob,
so they can eventually
communicate in a secure way
regardless of the pirates or
whoever else is listening.
So the problem here, of
course, is that if you just
send a message on a boat-- so
the pirates are kind of nice,
in a way, that they
will deliver messages.
But they are curious, right?
So they're very curious.
And they will open up boxes.
And so that's supposed to
be a boat, by the way, not
a box, a little mast there.
So I'm not a sailor.
But you have these boxes that
are going to get delivered.
And the deal is this.
If there's an open box, the
pirate's will open the box.
And if there's any message
in it, they might read it,
they might throw it away.
So clearly, a secret
key can be exchanged
by just putting a box
with a message in it
if you don't lock it.
They will not be able to
open, they'll not touch,
and they will
deliver a locked box.
But if they ever see a
key, they'll keep it.
If they ever see kind
of a key on the boat,
they'll just grab
it and keep it.
And then the next time
around, they see a locked box,
they'll stick the key
in and try and open it.
All right.
So how do Alice and Bob
securely exchange a secret
where security is based
on this notion of piracy,
I guess, with the pirates having
a certain amount of capability
in terms of storing keys,
and opening up the locks,
but they will not
touch a locked box?
All right.
So that's the puzzle.
How many of you have heard
of this puzzle before?
So all of you keep quiet.
Someone who hasn't heard
of this puzzle before,
think for a few seconds here and
see if a solution occurs to you
with respect to going back and
forth-- so that's the hint,
going back and forth-- and
being able to securely exchange
a message, which could be a
128-bit secret key written
on a little note
between Alice and Bob.
Yeah?
Back there.
AUDIENCE: Are they allowed
to pass locks such that--
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: So
if you see it locked,
they'll throw away
the lock, too.
If the lock is on
the box, then sure,
they will deliver that box.
But if the key is
outside of that box,
then they'll keep the key.
No-- this is a difficult puzzle.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Alice could lock
the box and send it to Bob.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then Bob
could also lock the box.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yeah.
And then?
At that point-- no,
you're on the right track.
Keep going.
Just push it a little more.
Couple of more boat
rides and we're done.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then
if Bob sends--
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: So there's
now two locks on the box.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: And Bob
has two locks on the box.
And so what's Bob
going to do next?
What's the logical thing
for Bob to do next?
AUDIENCE: Send it back to Alice.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Send it back Alice.
And now the key's inside.
Alice now sees two
locks on the box.
And one of the locks is Bobs.
And other is?
AUDIENCE: Hers.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Is hers.
AUDIENCE: She can unlock it.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: She
can unlock the box
and send it back to Bob.
And all of this time, the only
thing that's gone in transit
is a locked box.
No keys have gone
into in transit,
whether they're inside
the box or wherever.
But the only thing that's
moved is a locked box.
So that's good.
You're exactly right.
So that gets you a Frisbee.
Whoops, sorry.
We need a secure exchange there.
Yeah, that's good.
So that is exactly right.
So just to recap, Alice
locks box with KA,
and that's the key for
the lock, sends it to Bob.
Bob locks box with
KB, sends it to Alice.
And Alice unlocks--
oh, I should've said
that Alice puts message in box.
And that message has the
secret key inside of it.
Alice unlocks KA and
sends box to Bob.
And then Bob unlocks
KB and reads message.
So that's good.
That's all good.
Let's look at it a
little more deeply
and think about it from a
mathematical standpoint, not
a physical standpoint.
You could think about it from
a physical standpoint as well.
What is the relationship between
this locking, this sequence,
in this case a pair of
locks, that we require here
in order for this to
physically make sense?
s
I mean, there's
different ways that you
could add two locks to a box.
There's many different ways.
One way is to have a box that is
locked if I look it over here.
And it doesn't open, because
the lid doesn't open.
I've got suitcases like that.
And then there could
be another spot here
that looks it as well.
So that could be one way.
Well, what's another
way of having two locks?
Yeah
AUDIENCE: Putting
a box within a box.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yeah,
putting a box within a box.
That's great.
So if you put a box within
a box, then does this work?
It doesn't work, right?
So nested locks
actually don't work.
Because what happened here is
that KA was put first, then KB.
And if, in fact, you had
KA, and then KB out there,
then you can't remove
KA without removing KB.
And this would be the case
where you have nested locks.
So the mathematical
operation that we require
is commutativity
between the locks.
And the locks need to commute.
I want to put KA in first.
Like I described, the
physical realization
could simply be a suitcase
with two different positions
for the two locks.
And any one of those
positions locks the suitcase.
So you put KA here, KB here.
And then you can
take KA out, right?
And it's still locked,
because you have KB.
So this commutativity between
the locks and essentially
the keys is what's required.
And so now, let's
move away from pirates
and go into the
cryptography domain,
pure mathematical
domain, and see
how this turns
into what's called
the Diffie-Hellman key exchange,
which is a key exchange
algorithm or a protocol that
under certain conditions
give you exactly
what you see here.
It gives you a
secure key exchange.
And there's one issue
associated with it,
and that'll be kind of clear
once we write it out here,
that we'll get back to.
But Diffie-Hellman key
exchange assumes that you
have commutative locks.
And this is how it works.
You'll see what commutes
when I give you the equations
associated with
Diffie-Hellman key exchange.
And this is also
described in the '70s.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to work in a finite
field Fp*.
And the finite field
means that we're
going to be doing mod
p, where p is prime.
And the star means we're
going to be only looking
at invertible elements only.
So we drop the
nonvertible elements.
These things aren't
particularly important.
And so we'll drop 0.
And we'll be looking
at 1, 2, to p minus 1.
So all the numbers
that you see are going
to be 1 through p minus 1.
Now, what is the analog
all this protocol
that Alice and Bob,
in our pirate puzzle,
operated on or ran?
What is the analog in
the mathematical domain
or in the finite field domain?
Well, here's what happens.
Alice is going to
select a random a.
And we're going to
assume the g is public.
So she just shouts
that out to-- Alice
can see Bob from her house.
So she shouts out
g and shouts out p.
They're all public.
She doesn't care if the
pirates can hear this.
And Alice is going to
select a, which is random,
and compute g of a.
And this is in the
finite field, capital G.
So you're going to do your mods.
And she's just going to send
over g of a over to Bob.
Now, what Bob does is select
b and computes g raise to b
and sends that over.
So g raised to a is
being sent over. g
raised to b is being sent
over, sent over to Alice.
So Alice gets g raised to b.
And the key realization
here is that Alice
can compute g raised to b raised
to a, because she knows a.
This is all going to be mod p.
And we're going to call that
K. And thanks to the fact
that exponentiation
commutes, Bob
computes g raised to a
raised to b, because Bob
knows b, which is also
exactly K-- I should say mod
p over here.
Everything is mod p.
So that's it.
That's Diffie-Hellman
key exchange.
You have now created
a shared secret
based on the commutativity
of exponentiation.
And the part that's
still missing here
with respect to the analogy
is the fact that g of a
is essentially the locked box.
So what g of a is hiding is a.
Because you want a to be hidden
here and the same thing with g
of b.
It needs to hide b.
So the problem that the
pirates had was they
couldn't open up the box.
The problem that the adversary,
let's call them mal, has
is that he has to invert g
of a in order to discover a.
And in this particular
finite field,
and many such finite fields,
you can think of this
as being what's called a
discrete logarithm problem.
So if you don't
know how to computer
logarithms in that
continuous domain.
And there's tables.
And it's pretty easy to do.
But this is what's called
a discrete logarithm
problem, because we're
in a finite field.
And we obviously want
integers. a is an integer.
So we need to discover
what does that integer is.
Because we're doing
the mod p, et cetera,
and p is typically
on a large number,
it's actually a hard
problem computationally
to do a discrete log.
So when you see g of a,
you know g, you know p,
but trying to figure out
what produced that g of a
is a difficult problem.
And people have looked
at this for 30, 40 years
and there's not great
algorithms to solve
this problem, certainly
not anything that's
polynomial time solvable.
They're all kind
of subexponential.
And you can make the numbers
large enough such that g of a
is secure in the sense that it
doesn't give away what a is.
So that's the insight here
that Diffie and Hellman had,
which comes down to the
discrete log problem is hard.
And what this simply
means is given g of a,
the discrete log
problem is compute a.
And the same thing
for b, of course.
There's one other
thing that you want
to say to be precise
to sort of just
cover the spectrum with respect
to how this could break.
And that is what's called
the Diffie-Hellman problem,
for want of a better names and
since these are the folks who
first came up with it.
And the Diffie-Hellman
problem is simply
that given g of a and g of b,
which is what the pirates see
and what the adversary
mal sees, we should not
be able to compute g
of a times b, which
is exactly what we get here.
g of a raised to b
is g of a times b.
So given those two
things, if there's
a way of computing
g of a times b,
even though you potentially
haven't discovered
a and b precisely,
g of a times b
is just the secret key that
Alice and Bob exchanged.
So you're host.
Alice and Bob are host
if mal can do this.
So there's two
things going on here.
You want the Diffie-Hellman
problem to be hard.
And you want the discrete
log problem to be hard.
OK So generally, this is
how cryptography works.
You set up protocols.
And there's some information
that's bound to be exposed.
You want this information
to be hard to reverse
to get the crucial information.
That requires the computational
hardness assumption
like the two that
we've made here.
And then you're off and running.
Your system will break if
your computational hardness
assumptions are incorrect.
And they may be correct
for a particular time,
for example, the 1970s
for particular parameters.
But they may end up being
incorrect assumptions,
at least for those parameters,
at a later point of time,
simply because
computers got faster.
It's like 2 raised to 40
was this huge number when
I was your age.
Now, it's like nothing.
So that's basically
part of the game.
But the good systems are those
that scale where you increase
the parameter size and the
system and the protocol
stays the same.
And so you just increase p,
for example, in this case.
And the discrete
long problem is still
hard for modern computers.
So those are the good protocols
and the good cryptosystems that
stand the test of
time, not necessarily
the ones that have exactly
particular parameters.
That's hard to do.
Because as I said,
Moore's law and computers
have been getting really
exponentially faster.
All right.
So there's one main problem
with the Diffie-Hellman protocol
and the solution to
our pirate puzzle.
And so can someone tell
me-- and it could be just
for the sake of the
Diffie-Hellman problem or just
in the context of the
Diffie-Hellman problem,
but also in the context of the
pirate puzzle-- what assumption
are we making here
that's as yet unstated
with respect to this secure key
exchange being actually secure?
Someone.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If I were to intercept
a message from [INAUDIBLE]
something of their own back?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
What does that mean?
The pirates see a locked box.
So the first step of
the protocol, Alice
is sending a message
inside a locked box
with a single lock in it.
You're kind of on
the right track.
And what could the pirates do
in order to break this protocol?
We've kind of made
an assumption here.
And I might have
said it explicitly.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
throw the box away.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: They could
just throw the box away.
But that doesn't break the
security of the protocol.
That breaks the functionality
of the protocol, right?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Put their old
lock on [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Ah,
that's exactly right,
put their own lock on it.
You know, if they had locks-- so
these pirates don't have locks,
right?
We're making that assumption.
If they had their
own lock with a key,
if they just had
a lock that locks
and they didn't
have the key for it,
they will wouldn't
be able to break
the security of the protocol.
But if they had a lock
and a key for that lock,
then they can pretend to
have delivered this to Bob.
And there's no authenticity
here with respect to Alice
doesn't quite know whether she's
communicating with Bob or not.
She's at the mercy of the
pirates to deliver these boxes.
So if the pirates had a lock
and the key for the lock,
then we're in a situation
where Alice may have exchanged
the key with the pirates.
And she thinks she's
exchanged it with Bob.
And she's, in fact,
communicating with the pirates.
So there's a man in
the middle attack,
which corresponds to the
pirates having their own locks
and keys.
And it's even more trivial in
the case of our picture here.
Because assuming the
pirates know mathematics,
they can generate a random
number-- and the number
could be c, for example-- and
just send back g raised to c.
And for all you know,
they could actually
get Bob to send g
raised to b back,
but they would intercept it and
replace it with g raised to c.
And they know what c is.
So what's happening now
is so you can [INAUDIBLE].
I won't to go through
all of the math here.
But you can kind
of see it, I hope.
You end up, if you're
Alice, exchanging
a secret key with the
pirates as opposed to Bob.
And the way you can set this
up is the pirates actually
will get into a situation
where Alice and Bob think
that they're communicating with
each other in a secure fashion,
but the pirates can listen
to all of the messages.
They can decrypt
all of the messages,
because they know what
they secret key, k, is.
OK.
And remember that
the secret key, k,
is something that
is probably going
to be used in a symmetric key
encryption scheme eventually
to send real messages.
So you're going to have ciphered
text with that secret key,
capital K, over there.
And if the pirates or mal get to
know what the secret key, k, is
through a man in the middle
attack, you've got problems.
All right?
So the man in the middle
attack is something
that we have to worry about.
What we're going
to talk about next
is something that
addresses this problem.
And it may not seem
like it's directly
addressing the problem.
But fundamentally,
what's going on here
is you need to have
authenticity in who you're
communicating with.
Alice has to somehow
authenticate Bob.
And Alice has to
know somehow that g
raised to b is something
that came from Bob.
It's not g raised to c
that came from somebody
else is in the middle.
And that's where asymmetric key
cryptography and public keys
come in, where you have a
certified public key associated
with yourself.
And maybe you need
VeriSign or you
need the DMV, or the
Registry of Motor Vehicles,
RMV, to do this for you.
But you create a
certified public key,
which is associated
with your identity.
And it's public.
You can put it on a website.
And everyone can
access it using HTTPS,
so they know they're
going to the exact website
that you've put up.
And that gives you a way
of identifying yourself.
And if you can do
that, you can protect
against the man in the
middle attack using
asymmetric key cryptography.
So that's kind of the final
part of this puzzle that's
associated with authentication
and secret key exchange and all
of that.
Once we do that, you'll
know what the functionality
is that we require.
And then we'll have
to talk about how
we can build a subsystems.
Cool.
Any questions so far?
How we doing?
OK.
So public key encryption, let
me just do a little set up.
I said some of this last time.
But to make sure we're on the
same page, what we have here
is we really want a
message plus a public key.
And you want to obtain ciphered
text using this operation.
And this plus is not
arithmetic addition.
It's just that we're putting
these two things together
into an algorithm, a public
key encryption algorithm, that
produces ciphered text.
All right.
And this public key, just to
reiterate what I just said,
is going to be if Alice
is producing the message
and Bob is getting
the ciphered text,
this is going to be
Bob's public key.
And the fact that
it's Bob's public key
is something that
Alice should be
able to authenticate
using VeriSign, using
the Register of Motor
Vehicles, what have you.
That's what's going to
protect against the man
in the middle attack.
OK.
We're not going to
talk a lot about how
you can get a certificate.
Your MIT certificate
is something which
corresponds to your MIT ID.
It's got information, what year
you are, what your name is.
And when you generate
that certificate,
you are getting a certificate of
authenticity that you are you.
And of course,
you give that away
and you hand it to
someone else, someone
can pretend to be you as well.
But that's what's happening
when we talk about public keys
and you owning public keys.
We're not going to, as I said,
get into that very much more.
I'm more interested in
describing this algorithm
for public key encryption.
We'll look at a couple that
produces a ciphered text given
a message and a public key.
Now, of course,
what Bob needs to do
is to take the ciphered text.
And this is what Bob's doing.
And Bob has a private key that
is distinct from the public key
and needs to get back exactly
the message using a decryption
algorithm that corresponds to
the message that Alice sent.
OK.
And this whole thing is
going to work provided
knowing the public
key, let's call it PK,
and the private key.
We can't call it PK
as well, obviously.
So we call it SK.
Knowing the PK does
not reveal anything
in a mathematical
sense about SK.
But obviously, in order for
this whole thing to work,
PK and SK have to have some
mathematical relationship.
And the different
cryptosystems including RSA,
and we look at a
knapsack cryptosystem,
all have different algorithms
for encryption and decryption.
And they have different
mathematical relationships
between PK and SK.
And for each of
these relationships,
you have to show that
the adversary has
to solve a computationally
hard problem in order
to discover SK given PK.
And it turns out that for
most of these systems,
it's symmetric in the sense
that these algorithms,
at least for RSA, you
could use either one
of these interchangeably.
And there's issues
associated with that.
So we really won't go
too deep into that.
But what I said you should
hold, which is you have one,
it shouldn't tell you
anything about the other.
There has to be a
computationally hard problem
associated with
discovering one of these
only given the one other.
And we'll talk about
what those hardness
assumptions are certainly
for RSA and also
for another
cryptosystem, a knapsack.
So we're going to
present RSA, which
is this real magical algorithm.
It's amazing it works.
Every time I prepare
for this lecture,
I got to relearn somethings.
And that's because there's
one subtle aspect of this.
It's all about number theory.
Number theory can
get pretty subtle.
But it's also intricate enough
that I forget the details.
So let's get started on that.
Basically, RSA is based on
primes and factoring numbers
into primes and
using number theory
to make sure that you
can actually accomplish
what this is trying to do.
The functionality
of RSA should be
distinct from the
security of RSA.
When we talk about the
functionality of RSA,
we are saying for
any message, if Alice
uses Bob's public
key to encrypt it,
the ciphered text
resulting from that
should be decryptable
into exactly the message
that Alice sent given
Bob's private key.
That's the functional
requirement
of a public key
encryption algorithm
or a public key cryptosystem.
The security requirement of
a public key cryptosystem
is what I wrote up there.
It's the knowledge of
SK should be hidden even
given the knowledge of PK.
And there's precise
computational hardness
assumptions that are associated
with each cryptosystem.
So let's separate out
functionality from security.
We're going to talk
about functionality
for the next few minutes.
Alice is going to pick two
large secret primes, p and q.
So what I'm going
to describe here
are Alice generating her
public key and her private key.
She's going to then
publish her public key
and keep her private key secret.
Bob does the same thing.
And then after that,
they have to register.
And this is not something
we'll spend time on beyond me
saying it one more time.
They have to register their
public keys with the VeriSign
or the RMVs like I talked about.
So everyone knows that Alice's
public key is this long number.
But no one knows
Alice's private key.
So Alice picks two
large secret primes.
So these are actually
going to result
in the creation of
our private key.
And then Alice
computes N equals pq.
So she just
multiplies those out.
She chooses an
encryption exponent,
e, which satisfies this
little equation, which
says that it's relatively
prime in relation
to p minus 1 times q minus 1.
And she knows p and q.
So she can compute p
minus 1 times q minus 1.
So the gcd of e and p
minus 1, q minus 1 is 1.
And you can certainly
accomplish this simply
by choosing e to be a prime.
Because then a gcd of a prime
with anything else is 1.
And it turns out that RSA uses--
this is all going to be public,
by the way.
e is going to be public.
So you can just fix that.
And most RSA algorithms just
fix that to be a small number.
The encryption exponent
is a small number.
And the reason
it's a small number
is because you're worried
about performance.
And we're going to
exponentiate using e.
And the smaller it is,
the faster the encryption
is going to go.
So if you want to encrypt
fast and decrypt more slowly,
unfortunately, that's
the trade off here.
You would pick a small e.
And then we're going to compute
our decryption exponent, which
obviously is going to
have to be private.
Because that's part
of our private key.
But that's going to be
bigger if e is small.
And that's just a trade off.
It's symmetric in the
sense that while it's
an asymmetric
algorithm, it's kind of
symmetric in the
mathematical sense
that the private keys and
the public key operations
are symmetric.
So what is Alice's public key?
Well, Alice's public key,
which she can then publish,
is simply m, e.
OK.
Now, the fun starts.
We have to figure out
what the private key is
going to correspond to.
And it turns out-- and
this is one of those things
where how did they
ever think of this?
And that's still
true 40 years later.
You get the decryption exponent
using the extended Euclidean
algorithm.
And this is done by Alice
secretly, where what you want
is to have the relationship
that e times d is 1.
And this is mod p
minus 1, q minus 1.
And there's algorithms
out there that
would find the inverse
that corresponds to d for e
or vice versa.
And they're polytime algorithms.
As long as you know this number
here, mod p minus 1, q minus 1,
and you know that Alice
knows that, you can
get your decryption exponent.
And typically, if a is small, as
I said, d is going to be large.
By the way, the
numbers here, p and q,
are going to be the
roughly 1,000 bits long.
So that's essentially-- we're
talking about huge primes here.
And so n would be 2048
bits in that case.
So the private key,
Alice's private key,
you can think of as d, p, q.
So now, it's clear as to what's
public and what's private.
n and e are public.
d, p, and q are private.
So that's the set up for RSA.
And it's not at all clear
that RSA accomplishes
either of the two things that
we need, the first of which
is functionality, the fact that
encrypting, and then decrypting
a message should get
you back that message.
So that's the first
thing we need to look at.
And the security part is
actually a little bit easier.
Because you can see
we're going to have
to make assumptions
about factoring primes
and so on and so forth.
Right here, you can just
see that immediately.
The biggest
assumption made by RSA
from a computational
hardness standpoint
is simply that if
the adversary sees n,
that they should not be able
to factor it into p and q.
Because if they can
do that, it's over.
So that's actually easier than
the functionality argument.
So why does this work?
And amazingly, we can actually
do this in about 10 minutes.
I'm going to explain to you
why this works in 10 minutes.
And the only theorem
that we'll require
on top of this, which
I will not approve,
because Fermat proved
it centuries ago,
is Fermat's Little
Theorem that says
that when you have
p being a prime--
you can think of this
as a special case.
You take m, and m is
an arbitrary number.
And if p is a prime, then
this relationship holds.
So you raise it to the p minus
1 power, and you get 1, mod p.
So that's Fermat's
Little Theorem
that's going to be required.
And that's pretty
much the only thing
that you have to invoke beyond
sort of standard mod arithmetic
to show that RSA works.
So what's going on here?
Let's call phi p minus
1 times q minus 1.
Obviously, that's showed
up a couple of times.
And you may as well
represent it by using
a smaller, simpler symbol.
So we'll call that phi.
And we are going to
say that d equals 1.
Mod phi is given to us.
And therefore, we can say
that ed equals 1 plus k phi.
So that's it.
All I'm saying is the remainder.
Then you took to the mod
with respect to phi was 1.
So the actual number
was 1 plus k times phi.
k is some integer.
Think of it as a
positive integer.
Remember that we now have the
p and the q are over there.
And p and q are primes.
So p and q are primes.
And given that that's
the case, we really
have two cases to analyze.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I missed one crucial point,
which I should have told you,
which is I gave you this.
But I didn't actually
tell you what is going on.
I mentioned it in
passing, exponentiation.
But I didn't tell you
exactly what the encryption
algorithm was and the
decryption algorithm was.
And obviously, you
need that in order
to prove their correctness.
I mean, it'd be
wonderful if you could
prove correctness of this.
There exists an
algorithm that is such
that RSA works or public
key encryption works.
So it turns out it's
extremely straightforward.
c equals m raised to e.
And that's part
of the usefulness
and the power of RSA,
which is you take m
and you exponentiate it.
And you take c and
you exponentiate it.
And the first is the encryption.
You get the c
through encryption,
as you can see over
there, the ciphered text.
And m is the plain text.
And you get that back.
So our goal here is to show that
you have essentially something
where when you exponentiate
m raised to ed,
it should give you m.
For these choices that
we have, of e and d,
we've set up the d
in such a way that m
raised to ed-- because if
you just go do encryption
followed by decryption, you
are doubly exponentiating.
That make sense?
Ask me questions if
this doesn't make sense.
This is important.
m raised to ed should
give you back m.
And if you can show that
for any m, you're done.
That's the functionality of RSA.
All right.
So that's encryption
and decryption.
And so now let's
go back to here.
Now, ed equals 1 mod phi.
Because I've set that up.
This is how I
discovered d given e.
So that's a given to me.
That's part of what's called
the key generation phase of RSA.
And that's the
mathematical relationship
that I keep harping on in
terms of the relationship
between the public
and the private key.
So given that p and q are
primes, I have two cases.
The first case is
that gcd of m, p
is exactly 1, which
means that the message m.
So what I'm comparing
here, the two cases,
is I have the message.
And I'm going to
break up the messages
into two different categories.
That's it.
There are all kinds of
messages that are possible.
These are arbitrary numbers.
I'm going to break them up into
two categories, one of which
where the message is relatively
prime in relation to the prime,
p.
And it's not a multiple of p.
That's the way you
want to think about it.
Obviously, gcdmp would
be 2 if M were 2p.
So the case I'm looking
at is gcd of mp equals 1.
And then the another case is
going to be trivial, actually,
which is gcd of mp equals p.
Did I say 2 when I said
gcd of 2p, p equals 2?
Come on.
Wake up.
Wow, that's it.
Perfect.
Wake up.
OK.
So gcd of 2p and p is p.
So those are the two cases.
All right.
So by Fermat's
Little Theorem, this
is really Fermat's theorem.
And because he had a last
theorem, for some reason,
some people call this
the Little Theorem.
But it's Fermat's theorem.
And we know what that is.
I just wrote that out there.
You can now write something
that says what I'm going to do
is I'm going to just take
m raised to p minus 1,
which is 1.
So this thing is 1.
And then I'm going to raise
it to k times q minus 1.
And you'll see why I'm
doing this in a second.
Because I want to get the
1 plus k phi factor here.
So I'm taking 1
and I'm raising it
to this power, which obviously
is going to give me 1 back.
So all of that is
straightforward.
And then I'm going to
multiply this by m.
OK.
And this is clearly
the same as m mod p.
Because all I've done
is multiply it by 1.
All right.
So why did I do this?
Well, I did this, because I
want to group together these two
exponents.
And since I've run
out of room here,
let me just erase and
finish this properly.
The other case is easy anyway.
And so I can write this as 1
plus k p minus 1 q minus 1.
And that, of course, is
exactly m raised to ed, right?
And so what I've done here is,
because 1 times m is clearly m,
but if I look at this,
this is m raised to ed.
So that's clearly m.
That's it.
Just figured out that
when I have k phi
here, that's going to
turn into 1, basically,
when you exponentiate it.
So that's the hard part,
actually, as it turns out,
of proving RSA's
correctness, just
introducing this 1
raised to something.
And then the easier
part is simply
the case where the m is
actually a multiple of p.
So you have a gcd
m, comma p equals p.
And in this case, you know
that m mod p is actually 0.
Because m is a multiple of p.
So you're basically
exponentiating 0.
What do you do with 0?
You're going to get
0 on both sides.
So you're sending a message
that's essentially 0 mod p
And when you decrypt it
on that side, you get 0.
But one last line here is
simply that m raised to ed
is m trivially all of this
mod p if m is 0, right?
So that was the easy case.
So it was really
pretty straightforward.
In one case, we took 1 and we
exponentiated it and showed
the result in a couple steps.
In the other case, you had
messages that were 0 mod p.
So it's very pretty.
It works.
And so what happened here?
I said that m raised
to ed equals m.
And what I did here, of
course, was I did everything.
So it's not quite done,
a little slight of hand
here as I switched over
and talked about mod p.
So I had mod p over here.
And I said p and q were primes.
And I looked at p first.
But what I need to do,
just to finish this off,
let me do this over
here, is I have
to do the same argument for q.
And I'm going to put
it together for n.
And the reason for that is
simply that I have n over here.
So remember n equals p times q.
The encryption and
that decryption
are going to be done mod o.
Certainly, the encryption has
to be done mod n, because n
is only public
number that you have
that you can mod with, correct?
So what I've done here,
this analysis is for p,
can do the same for q.
It's exactly the same,
because p is a prime
and q is also a prime.
But I have to just do one last
thing, which is put these two
things together and say
that n equals p times q,
so the math is all
going to work out.
Let me just write that out.
It's not too
difficult to explain,
once I have this up here.
So in both cases of p and
q, so when I say both cases,
I mean the pk's and qk's.
I have m raised to
ed equals m mod p.
And m raised to ed is
the same as m mod q.
And since p and q
are distinct primes,
we can say that m raised
to ed equals m mod N.
And that essentially says c
raised to d, if you really
want to put it all
together, which
is m raised to e raised to
d, equals m mod N, which
of course is what we want here.
And this thing was also mod N.
This is mod N, mod N, mod N.
All right.
So that's RSA.
That's your first
public key algorithm,
the first public key
algorithm, at least
that stood the test of
time, still in use today.
From a standpoint
of computation,
this is the hardest part.
You have to exponentiate, and
you have these large numbers.
And as the years have rolled
by, RSA, as I've said,
withstood the test of time.
But the parameters
have increased.
Way back then in
the '70s, they were
thinking about 512-bit primes.
In fact, I can't recall
whether n was 512-bits or p
and q were 512-bits.
But if p and q were 512-bits,
then n would be 1024.
And now, NSA recommends
8192-bits for n.
So there's been an increase.
But the nice thing
is that it's not
like there's an exponential
increase in the computation.
Because the computation
is polynomially related
to the number of bits.
So if you double it, I
think, if I recall correctly,
decryption is going to
be the cube of that.
Or actually,
verifying signatures
is probably the cube of that.
But don't worry too
much about that.
The bottom line is
that as you double
the size of the
exponent, you're going
to have a fairly small
increase in the time required
to decrypt or to verify
a signature, et cetera.
But it has grown from
512 or 1024 to 8192.
And so hopefully,
you all understand
how RSA works to some extent.
I just will leave it at the
hardness assumptions here
are, like in the case of
Diffie-Hellman, two-fold.
And the first one is kind
of immediately obvious.
Just like it was the
case with Diffie-Hellman,
where you had g raised
to a flying about
and obviously that
has to hide a,
here you got N, capital
N, being published.
And if anybody could
take N and factor it,
there may be multiple
factorizations.
But you're going to get a
unique prime factorization.
So that's what you want, that
unique prime factorization
of N.
And if you get that, then
you've broken the System
because you know
what p and q are.
And so this is all
public in the sense
that this algorithm is public.
If you're using RSA, this
is what you're following.
So the person is
trying to figure out
what the two primes are
that together get multiplied
to form capital N. And so
that's a factorization problem.
And so RSA hardness
assumptions are given N,
hard to factor into p, comma q.
And this is factoring.
And then one other
thing, which is
given e-- so you're
not actually breaking
the entire cryptosystem.
But you're breaking
the privacy associated
with a particular message.
And so you could break
the privacy associated
with a particular message.
You're given e,
because that's public.
And you don't know
what p and q are.
But you know that e is
relatively prime with respect
to p minus 1, q minus 1,
because that's RSA algorithm.
And that's a publicly known.
And you also know c, which
is the ciphered text.
And so what you're doing is
you're trying to discover m.
So you're trying to break a
particular encryption that was
created by the RSA algorithm.
And you haven't discovered
the private key here.
That's only discoverable
through the factoring problem.
But you could break
security if you
can find m such that m
raised to e is c mod N.
So you're doing the
searching for an m.
So you're trying
to discover an m
that you can exponentiate
to get what you
have on the right-hand side.
Because clearly, you can compute
what's on the right-hand side.
So this is simply
called RSA problem.
So those are the two
computational assumptions
that you need to make in
order for RSA to be secure.
Cool.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] center?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
So that's anonymity.
Yes.
There's ring cryptography.
And there's a whole
host of protocols.
I actually did some of them
based on RSA, where you can,
by collecting a bunch of
private keys together,
essentially set it up
so it can be verified
that the message came from
a collection of people,
but you can't tell which
person the message came from.
So there's just a
whole host of things.
There's thousands
of papers written.
There's a wonderful field.
I encourage you to look into
it if your interests are
inclined this way.
And it's just gone on and on.
It's become more important
with the internet.
RSA, the company, was probably
founded in the late '70s.
And they struggled for a while.
And then eventually,
they were used
for Secure Sockets
Layer in Netscape,
which was their big break.
And then, of course, Netscape
meant the internet was around.
And so really, the internet
made RSA what it is today.
And so just a whole
host of wonderful
algorithms out
there, some of which
are based in RSA and
some that are broken.
And so let's talk for
the last few minutes
about all of the fits and starts
that occurred in cryptography.
And precisely what
I'd like to focus on
for the time we have
left is hardness.
So we spent a lot of time
talking about hard problems.
And we talked about NP-complete
problems that are hard.
But they're hard
in the worst case.
So you have a situation where
you have NP-complete problems.
And I'd like to
talk a little bit
about the relationship between
NP-completeness and crypto.
Because we've made these
assumptions about hardness.
Now, what's interesting here
is that N composite is clearly
in NP, but unknown
if NP-complete.
So this is very interesting.
The tried and trusted algorithm
for public key encryption
relies on a
computational assumption
where the problem associated
with that assumption
is not even known to be NPC.
All right.
So that's kind of wild.
So how does this work?
Or why does this work?
Now, if you take other problems,
like, is a graph 3-colorable?
And so what does that mean?
Well, you have three colors.
And you're not allowed
to reuse the same color
on two ends of an edge.
So if you put red over
here, you can put red here,
but you can't put
red here and there.
And so that graph
is 3-colorable.
But if you had a click, then
this would not be 3-colorable.
Because you have
all these edges.
You have three edges coming out.
And so clearly, the
degree from a vertex
is going to tell
you what you have.
So if you have a
4-click over there,
immediately it's
not 3-colorable.
But checking whether a
graphic is 3-colorable is NPC.
You can use a three set
as a way of showing that.
So you can say, oh, wow, maybe I
shouldn't be worried about RSA.
I should just be
building cryptosystems
based on 3-colorability.
Because it seems like a much
simpler problem than all
these grungy map that you
have out there-- actually,
beautiful map that
you have out there.
OK.
So that's something that's a
perfectly reasonable question
to ask.
And then we have Knapsack.
Knapsack is simply you've
got a bunch of items
and you just want to
figure out whether you
can get this particular sum
S. Knapsack is NPC as well.
And you got a bunch of
weights given to you.
And the BI are going
to have to be 0, 1.
So you just want to discover
a particular assignment
of the BIs, such that you pick
the appropriate items to put
into the knapsack, right?
That's it.
That's a perfectly
reasonable problem
to potentially use as a basis
for computational hardness
to go build cryptosystems.
And people did that.
People did that for years.
They tried and they tried.
And they produced cryptosystems,
public key cryptosystems,
based on Knapsack
that look fantastic.
And they work from a
functionality standpoint
in the sense that you
would use this Knapsack--
and I'll give you
a sense of how this
is done in a minute--
problem to encrypt.
And then you'd use a different
kind of Knapsack problem
to decrypt.
And when you encrypt
it and decrypt it,
you did get that
same message back,
except the whole world
knew what the message was.
Because the problem
associated with the Knapsack
wasn't hard enough.
So the computational
hardness was what
broke the Knapsack schemes.
And then you come
down to asking why
is it that this problem
that's not an NPC
seems to have stood
the test of time,
but all these other
problems, like Knapsack
and 3-colorability, which
is even worse than Knapsack,
when people have built
cryptosystems based on this,
they've all been
broken very quickly?
And so why is that?
What do you think the reason
is, sort of at a high level?
What does NP-completenss say?
When we talk about complexity,
what are we worried about?
Most of the time,
what are we talking
about when we talk about
complexity of an algorithm?
Or in this case, in the case
of a problem, what adjective
do we put in front of
runtime, for example,
then we compute complexity?
AUDIENCE: Worst [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Worst case, right?
Worst case.
In the worst case,
you're going to be
able to create
random graphs where
it takes exponential time
to discover whether they're
3-colorable or not.
But in the average
case, all you do
is if you have a large
graph, if there's
one little 4-click in the
graph and you can find it,
instantly you know that
it's not 3-colorable, right?
So it turns out that's
3-colorability is
just the worst thing ever
when it comes to cryptography.
Because the larger
the graph-- and you
need this graph to be large.
Because anything that's small,
is constant time, right?
Because so what if
it's exponential?
It's constant time.
So you need the
graph to be large.
When you have a random
graph that's large,
the chances you're going to
find a 4-click in a 2,000 vertex
graph is pretty high.
And so if you just go scan
and look for a 4-click,
instantly you know that this
graph is not 3-colorable,
right?
So in the average case,
3-colorability is easy.
It's easy to solve
in the average case.
And the wonderful
thing about factoring
is as long as the
numbers are large,
doesn't matter what
the numbers are,
it's hard to factor
in the average case.
So that's the big difference.
If you're going to take anything
away from the rest of this,
it's the difference
between problems
that cryptographics
systems are based on.
The systems that have
stood the test of time,
they're based on problems
that are hard on the average.
And the NP-complete problems,
like the simple ones
here, are hard in
the worst case.
And this is also
true for Knapsack.
So that's the essence of it.
I'll just give you a sense.
You can read the notes.
There's a way of
generating secret keys
and public keys using
Knapsack that I think
is kind of interesting
that is worth looking at,
even though all of these
systems are broken.
It's just kind of cool.
You know, how would you get
encryption out of a knapsack?
I mean, you're putting
things in a knapsack
and taking things out.
How can you set it up so you
get an asymmetric key system,
a public key system,
through a Knapsack problem?
So I'll just give
you a sense of that.
And you can read.
I won't finish.
But I'd like to do what we
did here for RSA in the time
that I have left for Knapsack.
That is kind of cool.
You get a sense of the variety
of different public key
cryptosystems that are out there
by looking at something that
is very different from RSA.
So in the Knapsack problem,
the general Knapsack problem,
what's hard is NPC.
There's a super increasing
Knapsack problem that's easy,
that can be solved
in linear time.
What is a super
increasing knapsack?
Well, a super
increasing knapsack
is something where I
Wj has this property.
So an example of that
is 2, 3, 6, 13, 27, 52.
So the rates are
super increasing.
2 plus 3 is less than 6.
2 plus 3 plus 6 is less than
13 and so on and so forth.
Do you see why super increasing
knapsack is easily solvable?
I mean, what is a knapsack?
I got a limit on
the amount of stuff
I can put into the knapsack.
And I want to make to be able
to say yes or no in terms
of whether it fits
exactly or not, just
in terms of our definition.
So what I do here in
super increasing knapsack?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
from the biggest
to the smallest [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Exactly.
That means that there's a
linear time algorithm that
basically solves the problem.
And you know that
you can do that,
and you would get
the correct answer.
So that's pretty
much what you've got.
That'll give you
the highest weight.
If you have 13 exactly, you
know you can't put 52 and 27.
You get 13.
There's no point in
putting 2 and 3 and 6,
because that's not
going to give you 13.
So that's clearly easy.
So we've got an
interesting case here,
assuming this is all
going to work out
from an adversarial standpoint,
which unfortunately it doesn't,
you can look and say, ah,
I want encryption to be
the super increasing knapsack.
Because that should
be easy to do.
And I want the decryption,
not knowing the private key,
to be as hard as knapsack.
OK.
So that's the kind of
thing that you could
do if you built a cryptosystem.
And people did,
Merkle and Hellman.
Hellman is the same guy, the
second name, in Diffie-Hellman.
They proposed this particular
system that ended up
being broken soon after.
But the idea is that you
create a private key.
And the private key is a
super increasing knapsack.
And then you use a
private transform in order
to get a-- and this is
really I put it in quotes,
because this was the bug--
"hard" Knapsack problem.
And this corresponded
to the public key.
And so what you do
is you won't actually
have to solve Knapsack for
encryption, the hard problem.
The encryption would
just simply take
the public key, which
is completely public,
and you would create
the encryption
of a message using this
particular public key
in a polynomial time.
But the inversion, not
knowing the private key,
you would force the
adversary to solve
what you think was hard
general Knapsack problem
to actually break the scheme
or to get the decryption.
And so let me show you
really quickly how this
works with numbers.
And we won't have you worry
about symbols and things
like that.
So just give me a couple
of extra minutes here.
So let's say that
I had a message.
Oh, before I do that, let
me look at-- let's say,
that we chose N equals
31 and M equals 105.
This is actually the message.
No, I'm sorry.
Capital M is not the message.
These are public parameters.
And we're going to take--
this is a transform.
Oh, I'm sorry.
These are not public.
These are private.
My bad.
So what I'm going
to show you is I'm
going to take a super
increasing Knapsack.
And that's exactly
what I have up there.
So that corresponds to
an easy Knapsack problem.
I'm going to convert it using
these private parameters,
N equals 31 and M equals 105.
And so our private key is our
super increasing knapsack,
which is 2, 3, 6,
13, 27, and 52.
And the public key,
what I'm going to do
is simply multiply each
of these, 2 times N.
And I'm going to take mod M.
So for each of those values,
I multiplied by N, which is
31, and take the mod of 105,
and I end up getting 62,
93, 81, 88, 102, and 37.
So you can get a private
key and a public key
using this private transform.
I'll let you look at the notes.
But basically what
happens is when
you take a particular
message M, what you end up
doing is you want to encrypt
it using the public key, which
is this quantity over here.
And the way you
encrypt that is simply
by taking a particular message.
And let's say that the
message is written as 011000.
Then all you do is
add up 93 and 81,
because those are those two.
And you say this is going
to get encrypted by 174.
So the message
encryption is simply
a simple operation where you
add up weights of the knapsack.
So you end up
getting 174 out here.
And the hope is, of course,
that when adversary sees 174--
and this is the part where
things get a little iffy--
that it's hard-- you have to
think about lots of numbers
here, of course--
for the adversary
to figure out that that
174 is actually 93 plus 81.
OK.
So the diverse is not
necessarily an easy problem.
And that's exactly what
Knapsack is, right?
I tell you what the sum
is over there, which is S.
And I tell you what
the weights are.
And it's hard for you to
figure out what the BIs are.
So now you see why
this didn't work.
So you have to have
a situation where
in the average case whatever you
produce for the ciphered text
here, you're sending out
the ciphered text according
to this cryptosystem,
which is 174,
and you want to make sure that
the adversary can't figure out
that this is
actually 93 plus 81.
Amazingly, people thought
they could build systems
using this assuming
these numbers were
much larger than they are here.
But that certainly
wasn't the case.
Because in the average
case, you end up
being able to break
these systems.
The last thing
is, of course, you
don't want to necessarily
solve the hard Knapsack
problem associated with this.
So what ends up happening is
you end up using N equals 31.
So if you want to decrypt,
you have N equals 31
and M equals 105.
And what you're going to do
is take this and multiply it
by N inverse mod M.
So rather than doing times N
mod M, you divide by N mod M.
And you can do this
operation relatively simply.
And you can go back
from 174 to figuring out
what the actual message was
by computing this quantity.
So I'll stop there.
I didn't quite get to everything
that I wanted to cover.
But take a look at the notes.
Get a sense for why
the difference exists
between NP-complete
problems and problems that
were used in cryptosystems.
And happy to stick around
and answer questions.